my biggest fear is the educational
system the influence of two TV movies
certain things that has been injected
today certain friends to all of a sudden
get these guys to be boom they start
believing whatever happened there and I
lose them for 20 years I have one of my
sixth grade Executives his daughter oh
my God he says my daughter and I were
best friends he says Pat you don't even
understand
my daughter and I were best friends I
said come on bro I said I'm telling you
best friends she loved her daddy I was
her favorite I said what happened I sent
her to University every six months she
would come back she was a little bit
more angry with me I don't understand
why she says after four years her
promise was she would never leave where
I was living so she decided to go live
in L.A she can't stand what I stand for
he says he's getting the emotional says
you have no clown painfulness and I
don't know what that feeling is like
because my kids are 10 9 6 and 17 months
I don't know that pain yet because
they're still kids